le début de 2022 a été marquée par
l'explosion du volcan où gâteaux louga
un volcan situé dans l'océan pacifique
l'éruption a généré pas moins de 117 une
amie détecté dans 26 pays parce que leur
trajectoire était prévisible on a pu
alerter les populations côtières mais
certains une amie ont déjoué les
prévisions ils ont été détectés là où on
ne les attendait pas
hilton g pacifique sud 15 janvier 2022
le centre d' alerte au tsunami est sur
le qui vive
la menace est sérieuse volcans sous
marins ou gatumba gronde il est en
éruption depuis déjà trois semaines
à 17h20 un local une spectaculaire
explosion survient à ce moment personne
aussi mais c'est l'une des plus
importantes des 150 dernières années
elle libère 500 fois l'énergie de la
bombe atomique d'hiroshima
une alerte au tsunami est lancée
des vagues de 15 mètres anéantissent tôt
et nook ou des îlots situé à 65 km à
l'est du volcan plus tard l'eau inondera
les côtes des états unis jusqu'au chili
idem au japon cette situation est plutôt
rare car l'activité volcanique ne génère
que 5% des tsunamis
des détonations sont entendues jusqu'en
alaska à 9000 kilomètres du volcan
l'éruption dure moins de dix minutes ce
qui n'est pas assez long pour que la
quantité de matière éjectée des
influences le climat malgré cela des
panaches composé de vapeurs de gaz et de
cendres volcaniques s'élève à 40 km
d'altitude
l'archipel qui abrite lunga tonga se
situent dans une zone où se rencontrent
des plaques tectoniques
l'activité sismique et volcanique y est
intense
en surface on ne voit qu'une sommet du
volcan mais sous l'eau il fait 20 km de
diamètre il s'élève à 1800 mètres au
dessus du fond marin
d'acheminer du volcan d'où sort la lave
se trouve à moins de 200 mètres de la
surface de l'eau
ce détail n'est pas anodin car il a
contribué à la force de l'explosion si
la cheminée avait été plus profonde sur
l'océan le poids de l'eau aurait pu
étouffer une partie de la force de
l'explosion
dans le cas de louga tonga rien ne
freine l'explosion d'ailleurs la
détonation est si forte si puissante
qu'elle fait vibrer l'atmosphère de la
surface de l'eau jusqu'à lyonnais ce
faire
des dizaines d'hommes apparaissent
rapidement comme lorsqu un caillou
rebondit sur rennes et à jamais les
scientifiques n'avaient vu des zones
aussi étendu aussi forte c'est certes
concentriques on les appelle ondes de
gravité atmosphérique
plusieurs phénomènes peuvent générer ce
type d'onde notamment les variations de
pression atmosphérique
elles se produisent souvent au dessus
d'un orage ou d'une montagne mais la
présence dont de gravité atmosphérique
aussi importante au dessus d'un volcan
casse perplexe même si les experts ne
comprennent pas parfaitement ce qui
s'est produit ils émettent cette
hypothèse le volcan explose d'énormes
quantités d'air et de gaz chauds sont
expulsés vers le haut en altitude
l'atmosphère et froides et stables
la rencontre de deux masses d'air
produit un choc et de l'instabilité
pour retrouver son équilibre l'air monte
et descend un mouvement de va-et-vient
génère des cercles concentriques saison
se déplace pratiquement à la vitesse du
son et font plusieurs fois le tour du
globe elle modifie la pression
atmosphérique locale un peu partout à
près de dix mille kilomètres du volcan à
seattle aux états unis l'on ne parvient
à dissiper le brouillard sur la ville on
observe sans surprise des vagues
d'environ 1,2 mètre qui déferle dans le
pacifique mais aussi dans l'atlantique
notamment dans la mer des caraïbes
le phénomène est intrigant car
l'atlantique ne se trouve pas sur la
trajectoire des vagues produites par
l'éruption du volcan
les chercheurs croient que les zones de
gravité atmosphérique pourrait en partie
les avoir provoquées en traversant
l'atmosphère lourde aurait pu par effet
de résonnance amplifier la taille des
vagues ou même généré des vagues
inhabituelles dans le monde entier il
faudra des mois voire des années
d'analysé pour comprendre quels
phénomènes sont appliquées les preuves
sont claires l'ondh a joué un rôle dans
cette une amie mais de quelle ampleur
c'est la question à laquelle les
chercheurs devront répondre
[Musique]